Crouch low keeping close and looking for
cover
volunteers with the Georgian Legion are
training before expected Frontline
combat in the coming weeks
the unit was established in 2014 after
Russia's illegal annexation of Crimea
were dramatically expanded after
Russia's full-scale invasion of Ukraine
last year
many of these men are motivated by
history
personal Vendetta held since Russia
invaded Georgia in 2008.
this is not only Ukraine's fight it is
ours too I feel at home here my uncle
was killed by Russian aggression in 2008
I joined the legion to take revenge
these men are training on how to clear a
building
they've been told by their intelligence
team that there are both Russian forces
and possibly civilians inside so they
have to be extra vigilant this kind of
training is vital as these men prepare
for the expected spring offensive
the Georgian Legion has around 2 000 men
they have fought in various places along
the more than a thousand kilometer front
line
most of the volunteers have already had
combat experience either in Ukraine or
in Wars including Iraq and Afghanistan
the majority of Georgian of 33 other
nationalities fight and train with them
Kenichi has a three-year-old son in
Tokyo
after his divorce he resigned from his
job in business and came to Ukraine
children were dying children like mine I
saw the war on TV and was continually
troubled by it I thought it was
impossible to justify
Haru was a member of the Japanese
organized crime group the Yakuza
he served a 10-year prison sentence
before becoming a lumberjack he has two
children in Osaka
I committed various crimes in Japan long
ago I want to atone for those things and
heal my life that's why I came one
volunteer from Bolivia who refused to
speak on camera said he had lost many
foreign friends on the battlefield
the volunteers have paid around three
thousand dollars a month for Frontline
work the same as Ukrainian soldiers
we've had military training from the
Americans and the French it has been
useful I cannot say when the
counter-offensive will start but very
soon we will go and help our Ukrainian
Brothers
for now these men prepare to fight
Charles strap at Al Jazeera Keith
foreign